st. George's Chapel does have a history
of hosting royal weddings going all the
way back to 1863 that's when the future
King Edward the seventh as Harry's
great-great-great great-grandfather was
married so tomorrow's wedding is going
to look a little different Mark Phillips
is on Capitol Hill that's a short
distance from this location mark over to
you good morning Gail well as we know
the royal saga here is often known as
and described as a soap opera and this
subplot of the marriage has all of the
usual hallmarks high last-minute drama
who will be here who won't
what will they wear think of it as the
bold and the beautiful by the River
Thames for some the pre wedding party
has already started music courtesy of a
local high school band
Harry and Megan made their way to the
rehearsal yesterday much has been made
of the fact that Megan Markel is used to
being under the public microscope but
showbiz was never like this
this comes with horseback military
escorts from the household cavalry there
will be a strong military element around
the wedding associated with Harry having
served the bedding is he'll be in
uniform himself although that raises
protocol issues over his beard stay
tuned so now we know that Prince Charles
will walk Megan down the aisle but there
is still the question of what the tone
of the service will be oh my
just tell him about love Michael Curry
the American Episcopalian Bishop will
give the sermon probably not in a style
that hallowed columns of st. George's
Chapel Windsor have heard before here's
a taste
we do know something about the cake
being prepared by london-based American
Baker Clare Patek two hundred Amalfi
lemons 500 organic eggs apparently we
have a lemon sponge lemon curd filling
and then an elderflower Swiss meringue
buttercream yes the icing on the cake so
much of this plot though Gail still to
unfold and you're in a good position to
see and I think right about there right
got it mark got it we will bring you
live coverage of the wedding from
Windsor tomorrow morning our coverage by
the way starts at 4:00 a.m. Eastern 3
central mark said it best I think Nora
where he said it's about the bold and
the beautiful at the end of the day it
really is just a great love story back
to you guys in the studio agreed a lot
of celebration Thank You Gail